not as easy as i
remember
i don't like this richard
it's almost as if you can almost see
this spot there's there's something
right here
the bullying incident happened that
friday in fifth grade the more i delve
into it the more upset i am that i was
involved
why didn't i say stop
i have to speak to my classmates
whomever i can find i remember being a
bit of an instigator we all as a mess
kept on running down the stairs and
surrounded him kind of feeling guilty to
this day that i did something like that
richard and i are here to go to the 50th
reunion for grade school which is
strange it's morphed into a little more
than that
why do you think kids pick on weaker
kids it could be a sixth sense or
something i probably was not brave
enough back then to say that's not fair
i remember the circle and the chanting
being a bully is one of the most
disgusting things i remember being
really shocked by that kind of behavior
everyone carries pain yet through that
pain
i can now see yours
you